- So, did you have like a
secret crush growing up?
Like maybe in the public eye?
- I did, I did.
I had a few, but I think the one
that sort of trumps the rest was
I used to, by my bed
when I was about 16, 17,
I had a sort of glossy,
like picture-quality
gloss finished photograph of Liv Tyler.
- Oh!
- And I
used to give it a wee kiss
before I went to sleep.
(Kelly laughing)
And then, cut to...
15 years later maybe.
I'm in New York and I'm
with a friend of mine
who I'd worked with, and she's an actress,
and she was like...
I told her that story before,
and then she's on the phone
and she's acting funny and she's giggling
and then she hands me the
phone and it's Liv Tyler.
- Oh!
- I speak to Liv Tyler on the phone
and I don't know if you know Liv Tyler,
but she's got like the
sweetest voice in the world.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And she's like, "Oh
my God, I can't believe,
like, ah, that's the sweetest thing."
I was like, oh my god, I can't believe
I'm having to deal with
this and tell this woman
that I used to kiss her face every night
before I went to sleep.
(Kelly laughing)
But you know, she's very cool about it.
- (laughing) That was amazing!
The best part of that whole story
was your impersonation of her voice.
(audience laughing)